just the extreme competence you just see
how good people are in video games like
the level of uh play in terms of video
games like I I used to think I sucked
and now I'm not even
like I'm not even in in the like
consideration of calling myself shitty
at video games I'm not even I'm like
non-existent I'm like uh the mold yeah I
stopped playing but it's so embarrassing
it's embarrassing it's like wrestling
with your kid and he finally beats you
he's like well [ __ ] that I'm not
wrestling with my kid anymore ever again
and in some sense hacking uh at its best
and it's worse is a kind of game and you
can get exceptionally good at that kind
of game
and you get the accolations of it I mean
there's you know there's power that
comes along if you have success I look
at the kid that was hacking into Uber
and Rockstar Games he put it out there
that he was doing it I mean he used the
name
um whatever hacked into Uber was his
screen name he was very proud of it I
mean one building evidence against
himself uh but you know they like he
wanted that slap on the back like look
at what a great hacker you are yeah what
do you think is in the mind of that
guy what do you think is in the mind of
of us do you think they see themselves
as good people
do they do you think they acknowledged
the bad they're doing around to the
world
so so that Uber hacker I think that's
just youth I mean not realizing what
consequences are I mean based on his
actions Ross was a little bit older
um I think I'd Rush truly
is a Libertarian he was truly had his
beliefs that that he could provide
the Gateway for other people to live
that libertarian lifestyle and put in
their body what they want uh I I don't
think that was a front or a lie